welcome to
cost function in machine learning my
name is richard kirschner with the
simply learn team
that's www.simplylearn.com getcertified
getahead what is in it for you
we're going to explore what is the need
for a cost function what is a
cost function cost functions for linear
regression
gradient descent gradient descent for
linear regression
and gradient descent for neural networks
this is really the math behind what's
going on and it's important to
understand what this cost function is is
and how it's being used in kind of a
high low guessing game the computer does
for solving many
of our machine learning problems the
need for cost function
comes in a number of points one of them
is that after
training our model we need to see how
badly our model is performing
while accuracy function tells us how
well our model is performing
they do not provide us with the insight
on how to improve them
better and when we're talking about the
training process i'm not talking about
you
you train a model and then you run this
on there we're talking about
each time you train the model the model
itself is continually going through
iterations
and finding a better solution and hence
we need a correctional
function which can help us compute when
our model is the most accurate
a cost function is used to measure just
how wrong
the model is in finding a relation
between the input and the output
it tells us how badly our model is
behaving predicting
consider a robot which is used to stack
boxes in a factory
the robot might have to consider certain
changeable parameters called variables
which influence how it performs
let's say our robot comes across an
obstacle like a rock
the robot might bump into the rock and
realize that's not the correct action
it will learn from this and next time it
will learn to avoid rocks
hence our machine uses variable to
better fit to the data
the outcome of all these obstacles will
further optimize our robot and help it
perform better
the outcome acts as a cost function
which helps us optimize our variable to
get the best variables and fit our model
the outcome of all these obstacles will
further optimize our robot and help it
perform
better the outcome acts as a cost
function which helps us optimize our
variable to get the best variables and
fit our models
so to kind of understand this we're
going to look at a linear regression
model
and the cost function for linear
regression it uses a straight line to
fit the model
this is done using the equation for a
straight line as shown
this should look familiar as your
euclidean geometry
you have y equals ax plus b
where a and b a is a slope and b is the
intercept
in this case we'll call it output equals
a times
input plus b for the intercept in the
equation we can see there are two
entities which can have changeable
valuables or variables
we have a which is the slope of the line
and
b which is the intercept on the y axis
if at first the variables are not
properly optimized we get a line which
might not properly fit our model
and you can see this line as you draw it
through the data
might give us a very skewed setup it
might predict one point of data
have a small error and a couple of them
and then a huge error on the other four
pieces of data going in
and this is when we start talking about
error
we're looking more at numbers than a
single
on off obstacle so it's more regression
you'll think regression numbers
if you've seen some of our other videos
so we're looking at
the numbers how can we minimize the
error
and as we optimize the values of our
model for some variables we will get the
perfect
fit for our linear regression model
the cost function will be the minimum of
the root mean
squared error of our model obtained by
subtracting the predicted values from
our actual values
our cost function will be the minimum of
these error values
and you can see we have our output y
equals a
input you could say a input x plus b
and so in this case i just went ahead
and left it as
output well let's look at the cost
function the cost function j equals 1
over n so we're summing up
all of our you know outputs to inputs
and it's based on what we predicted it's
going to be so that was the output of
our formula
minus the actual value that we're
looking for
and we square that for our linear
regression model the cost function will
be the minimum
of the root mean squared error for our
model obtained by subtracting the
predicted values from the actual values
our cost function will be the minimum of
these error values
when you think of this and you're
computing this in on a computer
like you know my mind is trying to look
at this long formula it's not really
that long
really you're you're adding them up one
at a time so that makes it a lot easier
your data comes in and you say hey this
is what the answer is and then it goes
back and says oh
these are what the answer was supposed
to be and then you can compute each line
one at a time
and easily add them up to get your cost
function on there
and we talk about cost functions we
certainly look at that in the linear
regression model
and there's a couple other ways to do a
linear regression model
but certainly we want to minimize the
error and we'd look at a cost function
for our neural networks
neural networks are interesting because
they have multiple layers on there
and a neural network is a machine
learning algorithm which takes in
multiple inputs
runs them through an algorithm and
essentially sums the output of the
different algorithms to get a final
output
the cost function of a neural network
will be the sum of the errors
in each layer this is done by finding
the error at each layer first and then
summing the individual errors up to get
a total error
the cost function of a neural network
will be the sum of errors in each layer
this is done by finding the air at each
layer first the air function will depend
on the model used
at each layer and that's important to
note if you're working with neural
network it's based on the model used on
each layer
so there's a whole other level in here
that we're not going to address on
neural networks
maybe i'll mention a little bit when we
look at the code down here in just a
minute
the below function is for linear
regression model
so we have a cost function which equals
the sum of the actual minus the
predicted
there's our error squared one over the
number of observations
uh so if you have if you're if you have
a hundred points of data going in
and you calculate your actual values
minus the predicted values you have to
divide it by a hundred
that way when you look at the cost
function over the next set up they're
very uniform and you don't end up
getting a bias on there
and so we can see here the cost function
equals 1 over n
times i equals 0 to n of y of i minus mx
of i plus b squared
now when we're solving this we have a
gradient descent
gradient descent is an algorithm which
is used to optimize the cost function
or the error of the model it is used to
find the
minimum value of error possible in our
model
when you're writing code this comes up
there isn't
a maximize function if you go into most
of like scikit-learn
a lot of the other packages in python
they have a minimize function not a
maximized function
because we are expecting this that the
error will never
be unlimited you're always your error
can go to zero it can't go to negative
infinity
and so you're always looking for the
minimum because you know it's not going
to be
an open ended formula when you look for
that minimum and so the gradient descent
can be visualized as a ball rolling down
a hill
in this case the ball will row to the
lowest point in the hill
this point can be taken as a point where
the error is
leased for any model the error will be
minimum
at one point and will increase again
after that the graph shows the error in
a model
and again this comes off with the fact
that we're squaring the error
the error that the best area you can
have is zero um
but even if you have like a negative
error it gets squared and so you have
uh it's plus or minus one it's not
looked at
as a negative error and a plus error
it's just how far off are we from the
least amount of error in gradient
descent we find the error in our model
for different values of
input variables you can see here we have
our error 1 listed there
this is repeated and soon we see that
the error values keep getting smaller
and smaller
this is repeated and soon we see that
the error values keep getting smaller
and smaller
and it just keeps going down until you
find the bottom of our little
downward loop on our errors and so we
can take that and the air graph for
linear regressions is given
this graph is obtained using the cost
function j
you see the cost function j this should
look familiar now
we have our predict minus our actual
squared and we're summing it up over the
total number that we're computing that
under
we must reach the lowest point in the
graph this can be done by traversing the
graph from any point and moving to the
point where the error
is lower now i know this is a little
repetitive but this is going to make a
sense why
why we're repeating here in just a
minute so
as we keep going down the hill the cos
the small difference between each errors
can be attained by differentiating the
cost function
and subtracting it from the previous
gradient descent
to move down the slope so here's our
cost function of j
and then we go ahead and try new numbers
and the gradient descent is going to be
our difference in those
and that's how we're going to look at uh
finding that new value in there
and if this is you know they put it in
the differential of j the differential
of theta
so you have theta j minus alpha times
the differential
we're just looking at the differences uh
just a fancy way of saying hey what's
the difference of our
last cost function minus the difference
of our new cost function
and so you get a gradient descent the
gradient descent full formula looks like
this with the
the original difference minus the new
difference summation
and and as we continue to go down we can
continue to compute the differences on
there to find
our new values in the above equation
alpha is known as learning rate it
decides how fast we move down the slope
if alpha is large we take big steps now
remember i said we're doing a lot of
repeating that we're going down the
slope and you're going to see why we
keep repeating that
and where the complications come in and
it's important to note
that we have this value in there of
alpha hey how far are we going to try on
the next number are we going to
jump way ahead are we going to take
little steps
and you can see that this happens we
might completely miss the least error
point and our results will not be
accurate
so that's one of the dangers of hi
having a very high alpha
and as you go down if alpha is small we
take small steps and we may take a very
long time to reach the error point and
waste computational power to do it
when we're playing with this alpha we
might be talking the difference between
a hundred iterations and two thousand
iterations when you're talking a large
neural network
and suddenly instead of solving this in
the course of an
hour you're looking at days processing
time on your computer
so it's very this is a big deal to start
understanding how that alpha comes in
and understanding your data and how it
all fits together
hence we need to optimize value for
alpha to attain the correct
minimum error value so we want it to go
down as quickly as we can without
missing where we want to go
for neural networks each layer will have
a cost function and each cost function
will have its own least minimal error
value
the error graph for neural networks is
shown this gets interesting because
you're going to see that we have
multiple
minimal error areas that come out from
the neural network
and this is also true even on some of
our regular models are more complex that
when you look at a polynomial
regression model as opposed to linear
where we're fitting a curve
versus a straight line through the data
you start having multiple minimals
and depending on where we start we can
arrive at different value
for the minimum error we need to find
the minimum value out
of all local minima and you can see here
we have
a global minima and then the two local
minima
and depending on where we start we can
arrive at different values for the
minimum error
we need to find the global minimum value
out of all local minima and this can be
a real challenge because if you're
looking at just one of those
loops you run into the issue that you
don't know whether there's other minimal
minima out there minimal values
and if one of those is the global
minimal value and so this can be quite a
challenge when we're programming and
writing these
putting together these different models
is finding
these different points especially in a
neural network again it's not just a
neural network that has a com up that
comes up
in a lot of regular solutions in our
different regression models
the gradient is sent for a neural
network is just a differentiation
of this cost function it can be written
as gradient descent equals
the theta j and then the differential of
j over the differential of theta
cos function j equals 1 over the total
number we're going to do and then you
sum up the total number of the
differences
of the y of i minus mx of i plus b
where m and b is your slope and your
intercept of your linear regression
model
the difference is we're doing that
linear regression model across
all the different neural nodes in the
different layers and that's where
you're summing them all up on there and
it still looks very similar
but it is done in a larger scale the
gradient descent for a neural network is
just
the differentiation of its cost function
and the equation
m is the weight of the layer and b is a
constant
called the bias and you'll you'll see
that a lot because
like in a neural network you might have
each
node will have all the nodes from above
going into it so if you have 10 nodes
going into it
you have to add all those nodes and they
have a weight the m
value and then the summation of all
those nodes going in all the values
going in from the above layer
then has a bias in there the bias weight
that's an added in
and then you get the full you can see
down here we have the gradient descent
of the
differential of j and the differential
of theta equals a total number
and i'm not going to go too detailed on
the actual formulas we'll show that in
the code
a lot of times these formulas are always
being updated so when you're writing
code for this it's important to know
these formulas a little bit
if it comes up you can understand why
it's doing what it is
but there's more than one formula to
compute this and so as you start
understanding these different formulas
you can start seeing how they fit and
how one works better than another
these are the most basic formulas that
are currently used today
and you can see here we form a nice
little matrix with the
1 over n of n of i of 0 minus 2
x of i y of i minus mx of i plus b
there's our
linear regression kind of set up right
in the middle of the formula
and then you have that with the 1 over n
of n of i equals 0 minus 2 y i
m x i plus b so you're forming a matrix
out of it
so as we continue looking at gradient
descent for neural networks
in the following picture we are
computing the errors for each layer
separately
and to this gradient descent will be
applied we also know that each layer has
a weight
which is assigned to it and so we have a
total error at the end
and here's those nodes i was talking
about you have your input layer it goes
into a layer of algorithms
you use the error from those algorithms
to program each one of those nodes
and one of the things they're not
showing here is each input goes to each
one of the nodes
to sum it so i guess in this particular
image the sum would be a single node
and then you have your layers each layer
goes into the lower layer and so forth
until you sum them up and you get a
total
error on the end the wave will be
different for each node in each layer
consider
a node in layer 3. the node will have an
output which may differ from the desired
output so layer 3 has our predicted
versus our actual wanted
output on there and then we create a
weight equals a new weight as a value of
the predicted output depends on the
weight applied to the layer
we can tweak it to get the desired
output we can similarly tweak
the weight of each node in the layer we
use gradient descent on the cost
function to get the best value of the
weights
which is a variable in the cost function
using the corrected values of the
outermost layer we can tweak the weight
of the layer before that
this will help us minimize the error in
the second last layer too
we keep using the corrected weight of
layer to further tweak the weight of the
layer before that
and get the desired output from the
network this is called
back propagation as we move backwards
so to kind of put that more in
perspective you have your output
you have your all of your inputs you
know maybe it's a picture with a million
pixels on it and you have a million
inputs
and it comes out and says it's a cat
picture or dog picture so you might have
just one
output um or maybe uh you have all your
inputs and you're trying to figure out
what the next
predicted value for the stock market is
you have a number coming out
we look at that error at the very end
and we push it back to the layer right
before it
and we kind of split it up between all
the nodes in that layer
and each one of those nodes computes an
error
then all of those nodes push back their
error to the layer before
and so forth that's what back
propagation is it starts at the end and
goes in reverse
so we've actually looked a lot of stuff
here as far as cost functions and neural
networks are probably the most labor
intensive as cost functions because
you're solving that cost function for
each layer
and for each node in the layer they're
all working together so it gets very
complicated
but the cost function is the same we're
still looking at the same thing even in
a simple linear regression model
so let's go ahead and take a look at a
demo on a cost function
and i'm going to do this in python
through
i'm using the ad account and navigator
to open up a jupyter notebook in chrome
we'll go up here in our chrome setup uh
and do a new python three
give it a moment there and so we're
gonna be looking at
cost function i'm going to rename that
and let's go ahead and start by just
importing our numpy
and our matplot library so we have a
little view of what's going on here
and then i have a data set that has a
just a bunch of random points on it kind
of
um we'll go ahead and just bring that in
this is a simple numpy load text because
we put it as a text
file probably could have put it as a
comma separated file or whatever
and you can see it's just a bunch of
pairs of numbers we have
6 11 17 592 whatever on there
and we can take that list of numbers on
there that was
pretty much randomly
set up on this and we'll go ahead and
plot it so you can see what we're
looking at
run and i'd probably spend a little bit
more time on here
playing with this to see what the
numbers are these are just random
numbers
so you know don't write too much into
them there's nothing fancy going on here
uh they do kind of group along a nice
line that's what we're gonna look up at
this graph and let me switch this this
is
sometimes we'll do graphs where we put
the x's in to make
it very clear that these are points on
the thing but let's just do a scatter
plot on here
that's all this is if you if you looked
at the last one we had
we did a plot x y rx
marker size 10. this
plot would normally do lines but we
change it to rx and we put a marker size
that's what gives it the nice little
x's but i like the scatter plot better
so we'll just do a scatter plot
and you can see the values kind of go
from 5 to 22.5
0 to 25 on the y axis and if we drew a
line through here
which is what we're going to be working
with this line would have a y-intercept
our b number and our slope m and we'd
want to just
fit this with the least amount of error
between all this data
and so we're going to go ahead and
create
and bear with me on this just for a
minute this part gets just a little
confusing here let's lift t off theta
uh we're going to take our theta equals
our numpy zeros we're just going to
create a zero array
and it's um two by one so it's just one
row that's two wide
and our new x numpy delete points numpy
s
one to one insert
new x zero 1 axis equals 1. learning
rate equals 0 initial
initialize b equals 0 and iterates 1500
times
what this means is that we're going to
start with
a flat line that equals the x axis
this is y equals 0 times x plus
0. there's our m there's our b there's
our slope there's our intercept
and the learning rate is going to be
looking at going 0.01 in its steps to
find the minimal error now we're not
talking
this is the distance between this line
what it predicts
which is going to be very small here on
this point let me just
there we go you'll see this point here
here's the distance because right now we
have a flat line
our flat line let me just draw that in
there for you goes here
and we look at this the the squared
value of this difference here
versus the squared value of this
distance here the squared value of this
distance this distance
and we're going to look at all these
errors and so we look at all the sum of
these errors
that is the area we're looking at is the
predicted
which is all going to be 0 so we can
just put 0 squared
and the actual um and actually did this
backwards
so the actual would be here would be y
square uh y minus 0 squared
so y is our actual output and then 0 is
our predicted output the first time
through because we set everything equal
to 0.
usually you guess a little bit more in
the first one
i would take when i write a script on
here
it pulls the first two data points in so
maybe pull these two data in
and it says okay here's our line with
our first two data points and then it
starts looking for
then it goes through and looks for the
error on there but this is fine we start
with zero on here
and so let's go ahead and load this up
so we have our
theta which is going to track the
differences
it starts off with pretty much just a
simple two points our first beta and our
first
our first slope and our first intercept
and so
we need to start putting together a cost
function
and again a lot of this stuff is in your
side kit learning
packages to find minimums and stuff like
that
and so our cost function goes in here
and it says m equals the length of the
points we're going to look at all our
points
y equals delete points numpy s
so we're going to kind of skip through
on looking at the y
and how they compare and we end up with
a let's see here we go if we look at
next
1 over 2 times n times numpy dot sum
this is just summing all of these values
up for us
and we have our numpy.power number
subtract numpy dot x theta
not be such a powerful array it's just
so fun to play with
it's a little hard to go backwards and
dissect this
but this is just our cost function on
here it's what we expected
and what we're actually going to get and
so
when we come out we print this we come
out we look at this we go okay so
this has an error of 32 that's what that
number is
that's just the first time through the
error is the summation of all those
lines to the x-axis on there
and we're going to go ahead and do theta
second equals numpy array
and it's going to be the same thing but
we're going to
just run this guessing at a second
number
based on the first number and it gets an
error of 54.
really this is telling us because we're
not doing we're not actually going
through the implementation of 0.01
remember up here we're going to iterate
learning rate of 0.01
we just went in and said hey what
happens if i take this error up here and
i adjust for it based on this error what
do i get
well my new error is 54. it actually got
worse
that's why you need a gradient descent
when we play high low
you might look at it and just pick some
random huge number you end up
with that kind of return on there
and there's a lot of ways there's
actually a lot of math that can go into
this
you might do something where okay this
is this error maybe we would
try a value on each side of that error
that is a quarter of it
so there's some math in here that they
do when they do the optimization
inside kit which which really does a
good job zeroing in on this
but to understand it it's better to go
ahead and do an actual gradient descent
and so we're going to go ahead here and
do cost history this is just kind of fun
equals the numpy zeros iteration and
then we have our theta history
theta second and so it's going to have
our first theta
oops
yeah that's right theta history which we
start off by just putting in the number
of iterations it's going to go down
and we're going to have our theta second
which is we're going to start stacking
on them and tracking them and that's
really not what we're interested we're
interested in the cost
history but it's kind of fun to generate
these values down here the cost history
is what we're looking at
and we start with iterating through the
total number of iterations
that's what we set up above uh which was
what 1500
yeah there it is 1500 so we're going to
go through 1500
iterations we're going to do our
production
our prediction which equals numpy dot
product x theta second
uh so right here we're just creating um
what we guessed a new number is
based on uh in this case our theta
second
is our um is our
slope on there that's why we're doing
the dot product
uh sloping intercept theta second so we
create our new
theta theta second minus one half times
the learning rate
there's our 0.005 times our x dot
t dot product which is a prediction
minus y
now this code looks a little confusing
it's
when you're digging through and you go
back you'll see how the numbers match up
playing with numpy arrays in itself is a
lot of fun and once you start playing
with them
looking at somebody else's code is
really hard to do the guys in the back
put this together for me
building your own code just becomes like
a very creative fun challenge to see how
it all fits
and how you flip the numbers around the
dot t means i'm transposing it
in a numpy array so i'm turning it from
columns to rows
and we're just going to take our theta
history and our iteration
and create a theta history and then
here's our temp cost
this is the one that's really important
uh it's going to be 1 over 2 times n
number sum and we have our numpy power
numpy subtract numpy dot
x theta second of y two
so we're looking at the cost of each um
iteration on there and this form comes
from here where we're summing the
all the different values and finding our
error
and then we're adding it on to theta
history and so here is our slope here's
our intercept and it just keeps guessing
for each one of these
and we can look at pieces of the history
and you can see it slowly changes on
here a lot of times i'll do something
like this and just look at the end of
the data
the last oh let's look at the last 20
run that and the last 20 you can see
that
62103261 602
this becomes a five a zero is kind of
bouncing back and forth on the slope
and it kind of zeros in to the six three
oh down here
six two nine six three gets closer and
closer to this one answer on there
uh but that's not the part we wanna look
at the part we wanna look at
is the there we go is the
cost history we want to take a remember
we're dumping on here
our temp cost and we're just going to
keep adding it on to the cost history
so let's go ahead and run that
there we go and you can see we have a
nice curve here and
what you want to notice on this curve
what's really important
one of the things a lot of programs look
for would be the elbow
not as important on this particular
graph
and somewhere right around here we jump
from
800 to 1400
with almost no improvement look how
small this prove improvement is
a lot of times this improvement as you
get down to here
is less than the actual
error that we have coming off of it and
so
when you're looking at statistics if my
error
is something like this here's my error
that means that these values right here
supposedly are getting better but they
might not be
so when you have when you start looking
at
the craziness of data coming in
and how it varies at some point you cut
it off and you say okay right here we
got to cut it off and you might actually
find an intercept here
usually though on the curve like this i
would look around 800 to a thousand
around a thousand you really are just
bouncing back and forth
between the bottom and in this size of
data that is
way beyond what this size of data would
actually be able to predict
um and that's why that's where you look
at these things you want to know where
where your points are and there's a lot
of algorithms to
guess where this best spot is but as far
as
understanding how we minimize the error
you can see we use a basic
setup to do our gradient descent to find
the minimal error
finding that bottom of our whoops that's
a horrible
loop finding that bottom of this
graph right here how close can we get to
zero there might be our zero line
so we've gone through a lot we have our
we went through a quick demo to show you
what that looks like and what's going on
in that minimize
routine using the most commonly used
gradient descent with a linear model
and we talked a little bit about how
that fits in with neural networks
pointed out that there's a global and
local minimals
all important things to understand when
you start looking at minimizing the
error one of the most commonly used
tools
to train our models in our machine
learning tool in our machine learning
kits
i want to thank you for joining us today
at simplylearn again my name is richard
kirschner with the simply learn team
for more information please visit
www.simplylearn.com
get certified get ahead
[Music]
hi there if you like this video
subscribe to the simply learn youtube
channel
and click here to watch similar videos
turn it up and get certified
click here